so we're on problem number one on the
California Standards test problems for
algebra two and so the theory being is
if you are able to do all or at least
understand all 80 of these questions I
think you have a pretty good
understanding of algebra two at least
from the perspective of California see
problem number one what is the complete
solution to the equation the absolute
value of 3 minus 6x is equal to 15 so
let's think about it 3 minus 6x could
clearly be 15 because the absolute value
of 15 is 15 so we could say that 3 sorry
that's a 3 3 minus 6 X could be equal to
15 but 3 minus 6x could also be equal to
minus 15 right because the absolute
value of minus 15 is also 15 so let's
write that down so or 3 minus 6x is
equal to minus 15 right if this was
equal to minus 15 you take the absolute
value get positive 15 so either of these
could be true so let's solve for X
subtract 3 from both sides you get minus
6x is equal to 12 divide both sides by
minus 6 you get X is equal to minus 2
and so here if we subtract 3 from both
sides you get minus 6x is equal to minus
15 minus 3 that's minus 18 divide both
sides by minus 6 you get X is equal to
positive 3 right negative divided by
negative so X is equal to 3 so actually
could be minus 2 or 3 and that's choice
B choice B problem to let me switch
colors to make things interesting and
there's a similar type of problem what
are the possible values of X in C the
absolute value of 12 minus 4x is equal
to 2 same logic 12 minus 4x could be to
write the absolute value of 2 is 2 so
you get 12 minus 4x is equal to 2
or 12-4 could be - - right because the
might the absolute value of minus two is
two so then you get twelve minus four X
could be equal to minus two right so
this is an or proposition let's see
subtract 12 from both sides you get
minus four X 2 minus 12 is minus 10 then
you get X divide both sides by minus 4
is minus 10 over - for the negatives
cancel out and that's equal to five
halves or two and a half or two point
five and there's only reason I thought I
wrote two point five I look at the
choices and they have them everything is
they have everything as decimals so
let's look at the other possibility
subtract 12 from both sides you get
minus 4 X is equal to minus 2 minus 12
is minus 14 X is equal to minus 14 over
minus 4 negatives cancel out which is
equal to 7 halves which is equal to 3
and 1/2 which is equal to 3 point 5 so X
could be 2 point 5 or 3 point 5 and that
is choice D problem 3 I'll switch to
maybe green problem 3 for wedding sure
Aida bought several dozen of roses and
several dozen carnations the roses cost
$15 per dozens of roses are $15 per
dozen the carnations cost $8 per dozen
so the carnations are $8 per dozen
sure Aida bought a total of 29 flowers
and paid a total of 192 dollars how many
roses did she buy all right so let's set
some variables that are equal dozens of
roses dozens of roses I hope you can
read my handwriting dozens of roses and
let's see equal to dozens of carnations
of carnations all right so they say that
she
a total of 17 dozen flowers so the the
dozens of roses she bought the dozens of
roses plus the dozens of carnations she
brought must be equal to 17 because she
bought a total of 17 dozens it also
tells us that she spent a hundred ninety
two dollars so how did we figure out how
much money she spent so she bought our
dozens of roses how should she spent on
roses well each rose each dozen of roses
is fifteen dollars so she spent fifteen
times the number of dozens that's how
much she spent on roses how much did she
spend on carnations well she bought C
carnate see dozens of carnations each
dozen was eight dollars she spent $80 on
carnations so her total amount of money
she spent it was that much she spent on
roses plus the amount she spent on
carnations and that is equal to 192 now
we have two linear equations and two
unknowns we can just solve them unless
we want to solve for the number of roses
that was the question so let's try to
cancel out let's try to cancel out the
number of carnations so if we multiply
this top equation by minus 8 we'll get a
minus 8 C that'll cancel out with that
so let's do that
so let's multiply that top equation by
minus 8 you get minus 8 R minus 8 C
what's minus 8 times 17 C 17 I'll do it
in the corner here 17 times 8 7 times 8
is 56 1 times 8 is 13 plus 5 is 1 1
times oh my brain was getting ahead of
me 1 times 8 is 8 plus 5 is 13 sorry yes
but it's equal to 136 oh and we were
multiplied by negative 8 so we put a
negative there and now we can add these
two equations 15 minus 8 7 r 8 C minus
80 0 and that was the whole point behind
multiplying this top equation by minus 8
is equal to 192 minus 36
let's see a little borrowing or
regrouping they call it now that's 12
that's a 2 it equals 56 7 R is equal to
56 so R is equal to 8
so sure ada bought eight dozens of roses
and that is choice C choice C problem
for problem four what is the solution to
the system of equations shown below and
there's three of them with three
variables always the hairiest problem
let's see we have 2x minus y plus 3z is
equal to 8 we have X minus 6 y minus Z
is equal to 0 and then you get minus 6 X
plus 3 y minus 9 Z is equal to 24 now
there's a bunch of ways to solve these
you could use matrices and inverses of
matrices and Gauss Jordan elimination or
you can just kind of use your
traditional you know multiplying
equations by each other and adding them
so that you can kind of constrain them
or take out variables and we'll do the
fourth we'll do the last one because I
don't want to introduce any other kind
of matrix manipulation here so what what
I want to do is let's use this equation
with both of these and try to cancel out
the X's right and the best way to do
that well let's think of how we could do
that well what one thing I like to do
just to simplify it is to get all of the
equations in what I kind of consider you
know lowest integer form I know that's
not a formal term but you look at all of
the terms in this equation they're all
divisible by 3 right so let's divide all
of them by 3 so this last equation would
become if you divide everything by 3
you'd get minus 2x plus y minus 3z is
equal to 8 so let's cancel that out I
just divided it by 3 it's the same thing
we remember whatever you do to one side
of an equation you could do to the other
side of the equation anyway so let's use
this equation in this equation and then
this equation in this equation to get
two equations with just Y's and Z's so
essentially we want to cancel out the
X's so to cancel out the XS with this
one in this one we can just add them
right because 2x plus minus 2x that's
going to cancel out the X's so we can
just do that and then when we do it with
this equation we could multiply
this equation times a minus two first
and we'll cancel out the X's there
so let's do it 2x so let's just write it
and I'll write it in green so if I add
this equation to this equation 2x minus
2x is 0 X plus o minus y plus y that's
0y these are all 0 but I'm just writing
them down there so that we're done and
then plus 3z well ever they all cancel
out plus 0 Z so it actually said that
these are is equal to 8 plus 8 is equal
to 16 so you get 0 is equal to 16 which
makes no sense and actually true so
there's actually no solution here and if
you wanted to think about visually
what's happening is each of these
equations represent the plane in three
dimensions and the only way you get no
solution or no intersection between this
equation and this equation or this
equation which is essentially the same
equation the only reason why you can't
get the intersection between them is
that they must be parallel into it they
must be parallel parallel equations you
could get an infinite number of
solutions if they were they actually the
same plane but these are parallel planes
so they'll never intersect so we saw and
it kind of makes sense because this part
well I'm not going to go to the details
we're just focused on solving problems
right now but it's fair enough to say
that when you add this equation to this
equation to cancel out the X's
everything else cancels out and you get
a nonsensical statement 0 equals 16 so
there's no solution and that's choice C
and those are parallel planes in three
dimensions problem five a restaurant
manager bought 20 packages of bagels
some bait packages contain six bagels
each and the rest contain 12 bagels each
there were 168 bagels in all how many
packages of twelve bagels of the manager
buy so let's say so the total number so
he bought some packages of six so the
packages of six plus the packages of
twelve that's just my random notation
that I invented he see he bought a total
of 20 packages so that equals 20 and
then he bought a total of a
sixty-eight bagels and all so how many
bagels did he get from the six-packs
well each of them had six bagels right
so he got six times the number of packs
so you got six times this this is the
number of bagels got from the six packs
and then he got this time this is the
number of bagels he got from the twelve
packs right the number of packs times
twelve and then that is equal to 168 two
equations two unknowns there are linear
equations we should be able to solve
this so let's multiply so they say they
want to know how many packages of the
twelve bagels anybody say they want to
know what P P sub 12 or whatever you
want to call that is so if we want to do
that let's cancel out the P sixes so if
we multiply that top equation by minus 6
minus 6 you get minus 6 times the six
packs minus 6 times the 12 packs just
multiplying this top thing by minus 6 is
equal to minus 120 now we can add the
two equations these cancel out that was
the whole point 12 times the 12 packs
minus 6 times the 12 packs that's equal
to 6 times the 12 facts it's equal to
168 minus 120 is 48 and so we get to the
12 packs there were 48 divided by 6 is 8
so there were 8 12 packs a manager
bought eight 12 packs that is choice B
and I'll see you in the next video
because I'm all out of time